jean charles marchiani s'apprête à
passer sa deuxième nuit en prison
l'homme de l'ombre de charles pasqua a
été incarcéré hier soir à la prison de
la santé dans le cadre de trois enquêtes
distinctes ses avocats parlent de
règlements de comptes mais aujourd'hui
c'est bien charles pasqua qui elle se
retrouve en première ligne
zine dine boudaoud philippe dumas jean
charles marchiani préfet de la
république
le couronnement de toute une carrière
une carrière longue et tumultueuse dans
le sillage de son mentor charles pasqua
jusqu'ici l'ancien agent secret préféré
l'ombre à la lumière
ses faits d'armes sont nombreux le plus
fameux la libération des otages français
au liban en 1988
parmi eux le journaliste jean paul
kauffmann scandalisé aujourd'hui par
l'incarcération de son libérateur de son
ami c'est jean-charles je pense avait à
le sentiment d'avoir été lâché je crois
je pense qu'il ya quand même une
certaine hypocrisie de nos gouvernements
à ils ont besoin et dans la bataille qui
se livre actuellement contre le
terrorisme
on a besoin de ces combattants de
l'ombre à cette époque jean charles
marchiani est encore très proche des
services secrets mais aussi l'éminence
grise de charles pasqua au ministère de
l'intérieur et qu'il passait des secrets
de la république à la corruption
c'est ce que semble croire le juge
courroye charles pasqua dit ne pas se
sentir concerné par les soupçons qui
pèsent sur son conseiller bien que
monsieur parce qu'on ne soit pas du tout
impliqué mais pas du tout impliqué dans
les affaires dans lesquelles monsieur le
juge courroye veut entraîner monsieur
marc annie on a le sentiment qu'il ya
une volonté de s'attaquer à tous ceux
qui d'une manière concentrique pourrait
rejaillir sur monsieur pasqua comme son
ami jean charles marchiani charles
pasqua n'est plus député européen
aucune immunité ne le protège donc plus
des foudres de la justice
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur est
soupçonné dans cinq affaires différentes